SPEAKER 1: Today, in honor of
Sustainable Seafood Month here
at Google, we are joined
by Michael Passmore
of Passmore Ranch and Chef
Bill Ngo of Kru in Sacramento.
And they are going to
tell us a little bit more
about sustainable seafood,
sustainable seafood farming,
aquaculture, and I
think they're also going
to make something delicious?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Hopefully so.
I hope everybody enjoys it.
SPEAKER 1: We're
going to go for it.
We're going to try.
So thank you guys.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Food in your mouth.
It's gonna happen.
SPEAKER 1: That will be the
end result, will be delicious
food in your mouth.
I'm going to go ahead and commit
to the delicious right out
of the gate.
So I don't have
to make it happen,
but I'm convinced you
guys are going to make
it happen for all of us.
So tell us, when I say
"sustainable seafood farmer,"
what does that even mean?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: It's a
big word is what it is.
Sustainable-- you know what?
We almost have dropped that a
little bit just because it gets
thrown around so much.
SPEAKER 1: We're
post-sustainable at this point.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
I think we are.
It's like post-modern
or something.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
We're meta now.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: But
it is super important.
For farmers like
us-- or any farmer,
whether they're land-based
or protein-based or anything.
Sustainable's part of our
DNA, or it should be, because
if we're sucking up
all the resources,
then we have nothing left.
And so it's absolutely been
a part of our ethos from the
get go.
And when it applies
to fish, it just
means that we're not
sucking all the resources
for feed or for water.
We're recycling,
doing all these things
that we need to in order
to continue to produce
that delicious protein.
SPEAKER 1: So paint the
picture for us of your farm.
What is it like?
It's 86 acres, but--
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Guns,
beers, motorcycles.
SPEAKER 1: Giant dogs.
BILL NGO: I can attest to that.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: No, in
all seriousness, it is.
It's 86 acres.
We're about to double that with
some other locations in Oregon
and around the corner from
us because of great demand.
But it's a bunch
of outdoor lakes,
and combined with some tanks.
And so we do what we call kind
of a bastardized recirculation
system, because we feel like
I'm not so focused on just fish.
I want to use that water
over and over and over again.
And so to kind of paint that
picture, the water comes up.
We have a great aquifer,
like a spring there.
Comes up, this
beautiful, clear water
that we don't have to pay
for, like the bottled water.
We just drink ours.
And it comes through, and it
starts growing little fish
into bigger fish.
But then once we're
all done with that,
then it goes into the vegetables
that you're seeing here today.
And we grow some
vegetables with it too.
So at the end of
the day, the water
doesn't just go away and go
down a river or something else.
We're using it over and over.
And again, part of the
sustainable part of things.
SPEAKER 1: So how
many of you have
heard of farm-raised fish
in a negative context?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: OK, fess up,
fess up, we all have, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I
think traditionally you
hear about ew, farm fish.
Wild, right?
That's the way.
So tell me why that's
not necessarily true.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
You know, I think
you asked the right
person on that,
because people say, number
one, what's your favorite fish.
And my favorite fish
is, well, mostly what
Bill cooks me, or slices.
But really, it's a good fish.
And so to me, a good fish
is a good, fresh fish
that's been handled well
and then processed well.
Well, that can happen in both
wild and farmed environments.
I think the key to really
nicely raising a fish
is-- we were talking
earlier about all being
shoved into an elevator.
Does anybody enjoy, like,
you've been in an elevator?
Like, in New York,
I was there, and I
think we were going to the top
of that really tall building.
There had to have been
25 of us in this thing,
and we were just like this.
And it was I'm just
breathing that person's air.
And then the other
one's in the back going,
[COUGHING]
SPEAKER 1: Touching
all of their germs.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: My mentor told
me it's really not that hard,
Michael.
Just--
[SNEEZING]
Yeah, like this guy.
BILL NGO: Just like that.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I was in
the elevator next to him.
But that's how
animals get sick too.
You shove them all in
together way too close,
it's not good for them.
So on our farm, we try to go
with a much less of a density.
And so everybody's
got a lot more room
to run around in there.
We're feeding them a
higher quality feed,
because we believe
that people like Google
here are willing to pay a
premium for the increased cost
because we're not
growing it more dense.
We are feeding them a
higher quality feed.
The other key to it is just--
[BEEPING]
--continued low stress.
Bill, I told you that metal.
BILL NGO: My bad.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: We're going
to get trouble with that.
I thought the Ansul
system was going off.
But that's really the key,
just not crowding them.
We don't have to medicate them.
We don't have to throw
all these drugs at them.
We just keep feeding them good
food, and they raise well.
SPEAKER 1: Plenty of space.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Yup, plenty of space.
SPEAKER 1: Good food.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Good food.
SPEAKER 1: Good water.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yup.
Good environment.
BILL NGO: The other
thing with the water too,
bad with farm fish
is all the waste,
when they're packed up so
much that all their waste is
going back out in the wild that
affects wild fish and water.
Like you said, none of this
water is going back to the wild
or streams.
It's going back to his
crops that he's growing.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: We push
out the nutrient-rich water.
That's code word for fish stuff.
SPEAKER 1: Poopy water, yes.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Yeah, fertilizer.
But seriously, it is some
of the best fertilization
you could ask for.
And so we put it
out in our crops,
and that's what grows some
of these flavorful vegetables
here.
SPEAKER 1: So it's not
just about taking better
care of the fish themselves.
It's also about taking better
care of the environment
and all of the other impacted.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Absolutely.
It's kind of like
raising good kids, right?
You were mentioning that.
Give them a great environment
to run around, feed them will,
give them room to run
around, and what do you know,
you've got healthy kids, right?
SPEAKER 1: What other advantages
are there to farming fish?
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
I think for me,
the thing that
fascinates me and where
we're going with
some of our things,
is not just in the rearing.
But in the rearing, if
I can keep the stress
level of that fish
at a very level area,
if they're not
stressed, then they're
not using their
energy in other ways.
So we can keep them just
super relaxed there.
They're growing,
they're super healthy.
But I think the real advances
have been in processing.
And for instance, when you
bring that fish in a calm state
and you're able to process
that fish without it
in a super frenzy.
You see these videos and such
where they're pulling them
in from something and
they're just all going crazy,
I mean, that has an
effect on the musculature
and the flesh and
everything else.
So when we're doing that
in a more calm manner,
and then what we've
learned, too-- like,
you're going to enjoy the
texture of this sturgeon
in particular, because
it's a real meaty fish.
Who thinks straight
from the hour
after you catch it is the
best way to always eat a fish?
Anybody?
OK, that's reasonable.
We all hear it's
fresh is the best.
That's sturgeon, if we
put it on that grill
like you're going
to see us doing,
and we did that right-- if we
just slaughtered that fish,
it would-- like a rubber band.
BILL NGO: Rubber
or leather, yeah.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: It
would just be chewy.
These fish need
to resolve rigor.
And so they relax, and it's
all about those processes
and techniques.
And in our environment,
we get to do those things.
BILL NGO: Certain fish
it's good to have fresh.
Certain fish you
want to age, though.
Tuna you want to age.
I use this fish at
both of my restaurants,
and we take it
even a step further
of letting it go through rigor.
This meat's really,
really dense.
Once you guys try
it later and you'll
see what I'm talking about.
We take it a step further.
We actually freeze it in
a slow freezing process
just to soften up the meat,
just to make it not as tough.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Changes
the molecular structure
just a little bit for it.
BILL NGO: Freezing it slowly
and then defrosting it.
SPEAKER 1: You're quite a team.
So how did you meet and
start working together?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I
thought I was going
to be the farmer's market king.
I had this weird dream that
I was at the San Francisco
Farmers Market.
I bet a bunch of you
guys have been there.
SPEAKER 1: At the
Ferry Building?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yup.
I was wandering
around as I usually
do, probably with a beer
in my hand or something.
And I look around and I
say, wow, this is cool.
I grew up in Texas.
We didn't have all these
farmers markets everywhere.
We ate well, but it's
more beef running around.
And I looked there, and I
was like, why isn't there
fresh fish here?
Because that's kind of
been a new thing there.
10, 12 years ago,
they didn't have that.
So now, I was looking around.
I was like, wow, there's a whole
lot of these all over our area.
I could bring my live fish,
because I didn't really
realize that you could
process fish at that time.
SPEAKER 1: Live fish?
Like a tank?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Oh, yeah.
We were going live.
SPEAKER 1: Swimming around?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Pick your fish.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: So
I'm getting to that.
And there's a really neat
guy-- Randall Selland
of The Kitchen in Sacramento.
Kind of a patriarch there.
Bill did his externship there.
And so he sees me at the
farmers market, my wife and I,
and sees these live fish.
And he just, oh my
gosh, what's going on?
Can you bring those
to my restaurant?
I'm like, yeah.
You call, I haul, sure.
What's the problem?
I don't think he realized
that they were coming in live,
and I didn't realize
that some chefs don't
know how to cut a fish either.
I'm like, well, you're a chef.
Don't you know
how to cut a fish?
SPEAKER 1: Uh-oh.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: So yeah,
this little pocket knife
has processed a
whole lot of fish.
Well, Randall was eating
at Bill's restaurant.
Bill's restaurant's
kind of like the spot
that-- the secret
not-so-secret spot that I
can't get a seat in anymore.
But he was in there,
and he started
talking to Bill about it.
And so Bill was my second
chef ever to use our fish.
And we used to pull the
fish bus right up there,
unload the live fish,
and in it went to Bill.
And that's how it all started.
BILL NGO: Picked out
the fish, pulled it out.
Love
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Tap.
BILL NGO: Gave it
the tap, and then
went inside the restaurant.
SPEAKER 1: So obviously
Bill's your second.
But what other chefs
that we would recognize
are you now working with?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Well,
Matthew Accarrino,
we were over there
defacing him over there.
He's a both very good
friend, but I don't know.
Do you guys dine a lot
out in Napa and Bay Area,
I'm assuming?
So pretty much anybody with a
Michelin star, or a James Beard
Award, or all those things.
So Mr. Keller and his
restaurants utilize us,
and Christopher Kostow and those
guys, good friends of ours.
And I could just go on and on.
Dominique and her places.
SPEAKER 1: Atelier Crenn.
Yeah, many, many chefs
who have joined us here,
and the ones you had--
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I
think they've all graced
this kitchen, haven't they?
SPEAKER 1: We're
trying, but not all.
We're on our way.
I've got a list.
So tell us what
you're making today.
BILL NGO: Today we're doing
a really simple recipe
that anybody can do at home.
It's poke.
Poke is a Hawaiian dish,
usually traditionally done
with tuna and onions,
salt, sesame oil.
But today, we're doing
it with sturgeon.
We're using Michael's sturgeon.
We're going to
sear it real quick,
and we're doing it with all
the veggies from his farm--
the fennel, the onions,
the purple daikon.
That's all from
his ranch and farm.
Cool.
Right there.
SPEAKER 1: And what was your
inspiration for this dish?
BILL NGO: It was
just [INAUDIBLE]
the ranch and farm, and
also, was it last year where
we went to Japan to check
out the Tsukiji Fish
Market to check out the
fish scene out there.
And right across
from the market,
there's a little market, right?
And all those little stalls
and street food, and everybody
was just doing chirashi bowls,
or fast-grab [INAUDIBLE].
It's just bowls with
rice, and they'll just
chop chunks of fish.
So this something
similar we're going to.
We're going to do a little poke
bowls with his fish, the trout,
sturgeon, and his veggies.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Actually, we were
looking for knives
at that moment
too, because the Nenox shop
was right around the corner.
And so that was part of it.
We were hungry.
SPEAKER 1: The market
just moved, I heard.
BILL NGO: Did they move yet?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I don't
think it shut down yet,
because Yoshi's--
SPEAKER 1: It's going to?
BILL NGO: It's going to, yeah.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
There's a fellow,
I wish I had his handle.
If you guys love
that Tsukiji Market,
it is one of the coolest places.
And one of our good friends is
a generations-old vendor there.
He has been posting some of
the coolest images on Instagram
just for remembrances for him.
He grew up there as a little
kid working his father's market,
and it's been pretty
cool to see that.
And speaking of
sustainable, he is
one of the few guys over
there pushing sustainability.
And he gets a lot of pushback
from that over there.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: What are the
main reasons that people
would say it's not beneficial?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I don't know
if it's not so beneficial,
but there's just
a lot of culture.
SPEAKER 1: Not as easy
to make a lot of money?
BILL NGO: It's just the
culture or the stigma that wild
is still better,
and the best sushi
restaurants what to say all our
fish is wild, or wild bluefin.
It's the stigma of thinking
wild the still better.
SPEAKER 1: It's just a stigma.
BILL NGO: Yeah.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Oddly enough, he
was the one who began to
bring our catfish over
to the Tsukiji Fish Market.
And here, sometimes catfish
is looked upon, you know,
I don't know.
But I love the texture of it.
And once again, you raise
it well, it's fantastic.
He was at the Monterey
Bay, and Bill was making.
And we started doing a
catfish sashimi, basically.
You remember when he was--
we were slicing away.
BILL NGO: And he liked it,
and he brought it over.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Might have
been a little sake involved.
A lot.
SPEAKER 1: Well, I am super
excited to try the dish.
Let's go for it.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Get to searing.
BILL NGO: So we got a
little sturgeon fillet here.
Like I said, it's been froze
and then defrosted just
to make this meat a
little bit more tender,
because this meat is really,
really dense and firm.
And when you freeze it slow, it
kind of breaks down the meat.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: So we're just
going to mark this real quick,
and hopefully not set
off anything here.
And it just takes a
moment on each side.
SPEAKER 1: Does anybody
have any questions
while we're watching this
deliciousness cook up?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I
raise white sturgeon,
and we also make some
caviar from that.
And I do a striped
bass, a black bass.
What else do I do?
A catfish and a silver carp.
And then I co-op with my
neighbor on the trout,
although we were
probably going to start
doing that in our Oregon project
and do a freshwater salmon up
there as well, probably.
Now you should ask me why
do I raise those fish.
AUDIENCE: Why do you
raise those fish?
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Because I was riding
on the coattails of my mentor.
I moved in next
door to a guy who's
been doing it for 35 years now.
World-renowned expert.
But mainly kind of going
back to raising fish well.
You want to raise them in what
their natural environment is.
And so for us, the temperatures
really worked for that.
So you have to have the
least inputs into that.
And so those temperatures, the
environment, the seasons all
work out very, very
well for those fish.
Somebody might say,
well, why don't you
raise a saltwater fish.
And it's just because why
try to create something that
isn't already existing there?
There's a lot of great
saltwater fish being raised.
But they're raised in saltwater
environments, obviously,
and then you don't have
to recreate that and put
a bunch of salt into it.
SPEAKER 1: Question?
AUDIENCE: So I
was wondering, you
mentioned that
farm-raised fish isn't bad
if it's raised correctly.
But if you're in the
store, how do you know?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I'm sorry,
I missed the last part of it
there.
SPEAKER 1: If you're in a store.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: So I think
one of the best references--
and I used to not think
this several years ago,
but they've done a lot of
work since-- is Monterey Bay
Aquarium's Seafood Watch.
I really think that they do a
fantastic job of researching.
They put the effort into it.
They are listening to all
of the communities involved.
And so they have both an
app, and you'll oftentimes
see that referenced on there.
And they don't
sell their ratings.
You can't get that
rating if you're just
really nice to them.
And I think they're just a
really reputable organization
that I look to, and
that we converse
with a lot on our rearing
practices as well.
Does that help out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BILL NGO: Cool, so
we just combined
all of the ingredients.
We got the sturgeon
marked off on the grill.
Some of the purple daikon.
The fennel, onions, green
onions, a little sesame oil,
sugar, and soy.
So we're just going to
toss everything together.
There's been many, many
variations to do poke.
You could use sea
salt instead of soy
and do sesame oil if
you're gluten free.
You could add whatever you
want in there-- the veggies.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: One thing I
forgot on your question, too.
Seafood Watch not only
rates farmed fish, but also
wild fish.
Which is super helpful,
because they really
do spend the effort, the money,
and all the resources to track
what species are being
overfished, underfished.
And not just that
worldwide but also
originally, in
different fisheries.
There's just a huge amount
of resources going into it,
and it's a major reason
why we support them.
BILL NGO: Cool,
we're just bring it
over a little bit of
steamed, organic brown rice
from our friend's farm,
Rue and Foresman Ranch.
Right there.
What else?
And we're got a little bit of
trout from his ranch as well.
Just putting that on the side.
SPEAKER 1: We have one
question over here.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could talk more
about the diet of the
fish that you raise
and how you keep that
sustainable as well.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Huge,
huge question all the time.
I'm sorry we overlooked that.
I'll speak from a couple
of different areas.
I had the pleasure of
serving as president
of our whole association
for the state,
so I can speak on that
level a little bit.
There are a lot of initiatives
into vegetarian feeds,
these type of things that are
claimed to be more sustainable.
I feel like we're learning still
a lot about that, where also
each fish is a little
bit different in the way
that they want to eat.
So those are things that we
have to take into account too.
Just like people.
Some people, they're
vegan or vegetarian,
they like to eat that way.
Some of us are carnivores,
and we grow and eat
better that way.
Fish are much the same.
So for my farm, what
I do is, for instance,
the sturgeon has a
diet-- it needs about 68%
of its diet to be protein.
And so we feel like,
as we've played
around a little bit with
different proteins within that,
we feel like fishmeal is
still a big part of that.
But I limit it to a less
than 15% of that 68%.
Let me know if
I'm boring anybody
with all these
percentages and such.
I can geek out for a
while on this if you want.
But what we've
found is that fish
is a large part of their diet.
So we feel like they need to
have that scent, if you will,
for them to be
attracted to that feed,
and to grow and be healthy.
But I did want to limit it,
because I didn't believe
in just throwing
a ton of fish meal
into it needlessly when
I can add other proteins
from other areas.
And the fishmeal that
I do put in there,
we spec that to be scraps
from other processing areas.
And so I feel like
that's a responsible way
to still get fishmeal
without sending
a boat out and harvesting that
just to go to a fish feed,
so to speak.
The other, well, about
14% of it is fat.
And then the other are just
the other essential vitamins
and elements that that
fish needs to grow as well.
Fat's actually a
really important thing
for sturgeon in particular,
because if you reduce
the fat too much, then
they're not reproducing right,
and all that great fat's not
going into that wonderful roe
that some of you guys may
like with a little bit of salt
and cured in caviar for you.
So the fat's very
important as well.
Yes, I'm sorry, I'm
probably speaking
a little ahead of myself there.
Yes, we contract with
a feed manufacturer,
and we tell them, we say,
hey, here's our spec,
here's our ingredients.
We want this to come
together, and I want
it to be certified to that.
I want it to be certified
that it's chemical free.
I don't want any other hormones.
I don't want steroids in there.
I don't want all
this crazy stuff
that maybe some other people
might like in their fish feed.
That's not for me.
And so they certify that
for us, and it comes out
into a pelleted form
of different sizes,
because when we have
little fish this big
to a couple-hundred-pound
sturgeon,
they're all going to take
different sized feeds
So we have talked about,
though, at some point, maybe
a finishing with some fish
or something in there.
But we haven't gotten there yet.
AUDIENCE: The first.
Is there a reason why you chose
to sear the fish today rather
than just serve it purely raw?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Oh, oh!
I know, I know!
I'll let you tell.
BILL NGO: It's just
a textural thing,
and to add another
layer of flavor,
to bring a little
smokiness to it too.
That's the main thing, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Great.
And then the second
question for you, Chef Ngo.
Were there any learnings
from Tsukiji Market
that you're going to take
back to your restaurant
and go forward with?
Tsukiji Market or
Japan otherwise.
BILL NGO: Yeah, there's a lot.
I think one of them
he just talking about,
he didn't get into the feed.
Well, he explained the
feed of the sturgeon,
but something we talked
about was finishing it.
We learned some of the
fish farmers in Japan
would finish their
fish with citrus peels,
or somebody will grind
down citrus peels
and put that in their
feed too to change
the flavor of the meat.
And that's something
we've been talking
about he wants to mess with.
So that's something learned
from the Tsukiji Market.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I learned
that-- what was a top tuna
auction that day?
It was like, $20,000
or something like.
BILL NGO: $25,000, yeah.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: And so
we're walking in there.
There's the fresh and
the frozen auctions.
And so we're looking around
and we see these numbers
on the fish, these
little stickers.
And I think that top one
was like, number four.
And so I'm thinking,
well, number four, maybe I
want number one.
Where's number one?
And all these are graded.
Well, you go over
into the frozen aisle,
and we saw like,
number rating 487.
It was huge.
So their grading
process is that broad.
I thought that was fascinating.
And the uni auction
was super, super tight.
And probably even more
scrutinized than the tuna,
wouldn't you say?
BILL NGO: Yeah.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: And
other than that, just
the sheer and immense
size, the variety.
BILL NGO: Just
the amount of fish
that is taken out of the ocean.
That's why we're going
back to sustainability.
Everybody wants wild
fish, but if you
see how much fish was going
through that market a day,
and that's how much is
coming out of the ocean,
you will want to start looking
for another source of fish,
which is farm-raised fish.
A good farm-raised fish.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: You
make a good point there.
I'm not against wild
fish whatsoever.
I enjoy a great wild fish.
I think what has been
impressed upon me by Tsukiji
is just that, by all accounts,
our wild fisheries are fully
utilized, because all of
us are eating more fish,
and there's more
and more population,
and everybody's
growing and everything.
And so that part of it-- we
speak about sustainability.
That doesn't seem
really sustainable
if we continue to pull
more, and more, and more.
And I'd like to continue to
enjoy nice, fresh, wild fish
too.
So I think that a good
farmed fish has a real place
in the community of seafood.
SPEAKER 1: So that brought
something to mind for me.
So we recently obviously
lost our crab season
for the most part this year.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Boy, didn't we.
What an impact.
SPEAKER 1: That's
something that may
continue to happen with other
fish populations in the wild.
As our climate shifts and
all these other things
are happening, is this
yet another reason
why controlling as many
variables as possible
could be beneficial in terms
of maintaining our supply?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I
think it does offer,
oftentimes-- I'm not
immune to having issues
with raising animals.
Animals sometimes do
have health issues,
or they die, or
otherwise, or have issues
like the crab or something.
But certainly we don't deal
with some of the oceanic weather
forces and warming or
otherwise, whatever
your particular
philosophy is on that.
And it does seem that some
warming is causing some algae.
And you hear about the fish
dying in a port or something.
And it's because
they're schooling fish,
they've lost oxygen in there.
And so they swim and swim
and swim until they perish,
because there's just
not enough oxygen.
I do think that that will
have an effect on and on.
And I hope that other folks,
aquaculturists, continue
to raise good fish to
help offset that and do it
in a responsible manner that's
not overly consuming resources.
SPEAKER 1: Are you
seeing in an uptick
in that idea of aquaculturists?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Not so much
in California, oddly enough.
I live in an area where there's
quite a few aquaculturists,
some long-time standing guys.
But in California, we're a
fairly small little industry,
oddly enough.
SPEAKER 1: That's surprising.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Oddly enough.
SPEAKER 1: Why do
you think that is?
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
I think that we
will see more as California
continues to think about what
offshore looks like for us.
Can that be done responsibly?
Can that be done in a way
that doesn't interfere
with wild fishing, environmental
concerns-- "viewsheds,"
I believe they call them there.
I think as we can
look into that,
I think you're going
to start to see
a lot more investment in that,
and a lot more production--
healthy production
for our state here.
SPEAKER 1: Are there other
parts of the US where
it's a more common practice?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: There is.
I believe the Gulf of
Mexico is doing it.
I'm not sure on the
East Coast right now,
but some of those areas
are also a lot easier
to basically put a straw in.
There is a abalone farm,
some friends of ours,
and it is one of the coolest
operations you've ever seen.
They've got a huge
straw, and it comes in,
and they raise
millions of pounds
of abalone, which is delicious.
I could eat that forever.
And then it goes back out
purer than it came in,
because the abalone
are a filtering device.
It's one of the coolest things
I've ever seen out there.
SPEAKER 1: That's fascinating.
I love the ingenuity there.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: I do, actually.
SPEAKER 1: Chef!
So, for the benefit
of our friends
who are going to watch this on
YouTube later, one of our chefs
is wondering if you'll tell us
a little bit about your process.
From the moment he places
an order, what happens?
How fresh is the product that's
actually being delivered?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Sure.
I'm going to back it up just
a few minutes though, here.
So when I first started
serving guys like Bill,
it was all just cut to order,
because our volume really
wasn't that big, and we
could make that work.
BILL NGO: It was still alive.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Well, this is true.
It was really cut to order there
SPEAKER 1: Real fresh.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
So then we advanced
into that Bill would say,
hey, I need this, and OK.
So we'd process it, and
we'd bring it over to him
pretty much day, thereafter.
I mean, really
short supply chain.
Well, when you start dealing
with the Googleplex here,
it's enormous.
I mean, Bill and
I just got crushed
over there doing sushi service.
It's like this wave
of humanity came in,
and everybody wanted
sushi, and I'm like--
SPEAKER 1: Did any of you
join them for sushi today?
No?
You did?
I missed that, I'm so bitter.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Were you the guy
that about knocked out
our friend [? Kimio? ?]
Was that you?
Somebody gave him an elbow
to get out of the way.
SPEAKER 1: That does
not sound very Googley.
I don't think that happened.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
It was good sushi,
so they're like, nothing's
standing in the way.
But what Chef brought up, what
has been really fun for us,
and what's been really
cool to work with,
like Lauren over there.
Hello, Lauren.
SPEAKER 1: Hi, Lauren!
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Is
working through how
do we get processed
an enormous amount
and still maintain our standard
of very, very tight-- now,
the sturgeon, we don't bring
that out for four days.
It really needs four days.
But that's factored
into our timeline.
The rest of it is day after,
day in, maybe 12, 13 hours tops.
Depends on when it
gets served to you.
But in order to keep
doing that, they've
really been working
with us with throwing
their orders out earlier.
This is what their technology
and everything does
for us, and their forecasting.
And it's been what an exercise
for us too, and a real pleasure
to work with the folks
that get all of you
guys this food, to be able
to utilize that to-- gosh,
we're bringing in several
thousand pounds a week
here to Google.
And to be able to do
that in a manner that
keeps that lead time less
than 48 hours, oftentimes.
And that's pretty incredible
at that kind of scale,
because otherwise
what's happening
is if it's out on a ship, or
if it's across the country,
then it's processed.
And not necessarily anything
bad about that, per se.
It's just a lengthier
supply chain.
And so then it hops
on a truck, typically,
comes over, and then
goes to the distributor,
comes over to Chef there,
and then comes to you guys.
SPEAKER 1: So we've got
an abbreviated supply
chain when we partner with?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Pretty much.
It comes from comes from
our ranch right down here,
and our drivers leave bright
and early at 3:30 in the morning
to get it to you guys.
SPEAKER 1: That's amazing.
We try to partner with farmers
locally as often as we possibly
can to make sure that
not just your proteins,
but your veggies
and all of those
are as fresh and
local as possible.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: You
guys do an astounding job
for the immensity
of the operation
and the quality of food.
I've thoroughly enjoyed it.
My lunch here was great today.
SPEAKER 1: We serve
150,000 meals a day.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Is that all?
SPEAKER 1: That's it.
No big deal.
Globally.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: And
Bill's looking forward
to a 12-person sushi
bar in the future.
He's like, I want to
serve 12 people a night.
That's what I want to do.
BILL NGO: That's it.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, sushi is a
hot commodity around here.
We don't have to many
sushi bars at Google,
but you certainly
saw the demand.
Anybody else?
Last couple questions while
our dish is finished up?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: And I will
say as you go over there,
if you are in Sacramento,
go out of your way
to go see Bill at Kru.
And it's on J Street.
I've been all over the
world, I love to eat sushi.
And the sushi that I've
had sitting at Bill's bar
has been, bar none,
some of the finest.
His sourcing, his skills, I
can't say enough about the guy.
I hope his head doesn't get
too big for his hat right now.
But anyways, question?
AUDIENCE: One of
the reasons I try
to get most of my
animal protein,
or almost all, from seafood
is-- this kind of terrible,
but I feel like
fish and things are
sort of lower consciousness
than land animals.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: They are.
AUDIENCE: But I'm
curious from you,
working so extensively with
fish, if you feel that's true.
I know there's sort
of debate amongst
the scientific community
about what lobsters
go through when they're
boiled and things like that.
I'm curious, just sort
of your experience
on whether this is true.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I
am more familiar-- I'm
glad you brought that
up, because I do.
I see that animal
welfare is a hot topic.
I haven't seen what
I would consider
to be irrefutable proof
showing that a fish has
the mental capacity
to experience pain.
When we talk about pain
and those kind of things,
it's different when you have
a reaction to something.
That is an environmental thing.
Does anybody
remember roly polies?
Everybody knows what those are?
I'm a Texas boy.
We used to get our little
magnifying glasses out,
[ZAPPING SOUND] you know?
They're not experiencing
pain, per se.
What you saw happening there
was just a physical reaction
to that stimuli.
So you were spot on.
Their neuro makeup,
a fish-- and I'm
not talking about mammal fish.
I'm talking about shrimp or
bass, these type of things.
They do not have the same
processing abilities as, say,
a human, or my cute
little puppy, or otherwise
to experience it in the same
way that some of, like you said,
your upper-level animals would.
AUDIENCE: You had talked
a little bit about stress
before, trying to keep
the stress levels equal.
I'm a bit more curious about
whether-- in your experience
of being a fish farmer
for a while now,
you sort of get to
know them a bit better.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Right, I'll clarify.
When I talk about stress, I
am talking about in energy.
For instance, if I am
thinking a whole lot,
if I have a lot of troubles or
something and I'm stressed out,
I'm not talking about if
I'm happy or sad in that.
I'm talking about
the energy that I
may be utilizing in order
to deal with those stresses.
I'm talking about
that with the fish,
not that they are happy or sad.
From a personal or an anecdotal,
if you're asking for that,
I do see behaviors.
I don't see personalities
in those fish.
They're really terrible
pets, quite frankly.
But certainly amongst some of
our larger sturgeon and such
that we're growing
out for caviar, sure.
Can I relate behaviors to
almost cute personalities,
so to speak?
If I really wanted to
stretch that far, sure.
But really, all
they're hoping for is
that I'm coming by with
feed when they come up
and they bring their nose up,
and they're looking, going,
hey, buddy.
You got any feed for me?
Because that's what
they're used to.
That's what they've been--
Pavlov's dog, basically.
You ring the bell and
they get the food there.
AUDIENCE: The sturgeon,
you raise them from--
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I should've
brought some, right?
That's the question?
"Where is the caviar?"
AUDIENCE: So you raise them
for like, seven, eight years.
And then in their first
full reproductive year,
you cut them open, take out
the caviar, and sell the flesh.
There's several
techniques that I've
read about for taking out
caviar without killing the fish.
Why have those not caught on?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Lots
of reasons, actually.
So first of all, I
will say that I'm
learning that I
really don't like
the first reproductive cycle.
I like the second
reproductive cycle.
It's a stronger, more robust
egg, these kind of things.
So you're talking about
no-kill caviar, right?
That sounded like a fantastic
idea, because shoot,
why couldn't we take a
resource, get caviar from it
year after year
after year, and we
wouldn't have to grow them
up to seven to 10 years old?
Wow, wouldn't that be great?
So here's the problems.
In any facility or otherwise,
like when they designed
this kitchen, the put a certain
amount of stations in there.
And so it makes it difficult
to facilitate more than what
it's able to do.
So in our environment,
you have things that
are sized to certain sizes.
So as that fish
continues to grow
in kind of a fantasy world,
so to speak, of no kill,
soon you'd be dealing
with a 400-pound fish.
That can be troublesome.
Bill, how is it to deal
with 150-pound fish?
BILL NGO: Crazy.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: They are
extremely strong animals.
We call them like,
monkey strong,
because when you're in their
environment, they outpower you.
So there's that aspect of it.
But when we get into just
pure quality of caviar,
and I've experienced
some of the no kill,
I think it's a fascinating idea.
But what I'm not
real excited about is
that, in layman's
terms, basically they're
injecting a hormone
into that fish
so that you can spawn it just
as if we were spawning fish
to make up our next
fish class, so to speak.
So you milk that fish,
basically pushing those eggs out
through the vent there.
Well, those eggs, then,
from those hormones,
they have a very porous
cell wall to them.
Porous cell wall is code
word for mushy eggs.
And as a general rule,
people who enjoy caviar
are not looking for jam.
They're looking for a
nice bead, a nice pop,
these kind of things.
So those folks knew that
and they said, gosh, we
don't want that.
We have to figure out how
to close up that cell wall.
So then they dip
it into a chemical
that then chemically
alters that and makes
that cell wall tighter
and a much tighter bead.
None of that really gets me
too excited, quite frankly.
I suspect, maybe at
some point in time,
if they could modulate that
chemical to make for a medium
or maybe not as tight, because
personally I prefer caviar
that I don't have to chew.
And so those are
almost like-- did
you ever decorate your
cupcakes with those little BBs?
That's what it kind
of reminded me of.
Flavor was fine, flavor was OK.
But I was chasing
the caviar around.
So I think those present some
issues for that technology
to go forth.
But in theory, it sounds
absolutely fantastic.
I think there's just some
logistical challenges to it
is all.
SPEAKER 1: Not there yet.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Maybe in the future.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Like
a lot of things though,
everything's advancing,
and certainly open to
if they can solve that one.
I don't think I'm going to
be the one solving that one,
but we'll see what
everybody else does.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Hi!
AUDIENCE: So different fish
are sold at different prices.
Is it harder to raise some
kind of fish than others?
SPEAKER 1: And is your pricing
model based on difficulty?
Is it a skill level?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I
think it's both a skill.
I think there's are some what
the market will bear or not
bear.
Like salmon, for instance.
Salmon has an awesome
marketing team.
I mean, we all expect
salmon to be on the plate
everywhere, right?
So I think that there
are issues of market
that go towards price.
Mainly what you're looking
at, though, is inputs.
So what does it cost
to raise that fish?
And that's not necessarily
given to expertise.
It can be like higher protein.
We were talking
about feeds there.
More protein in it,
those type of fish,
that feed costs a lot more.
So we have to factor that in
in feed conversion ratios.
I'm going to nerd out
here for a minute again,
but the better the
conversion ratio is,
the more you can
produce at a lower cost.
But yes, some of it is
rarity or expertise.
We are going to find out how
well we did at striped bass
this year.
I know that we hatched
nearly 10 million eggs.
Nearly 10 million eggs!
But I don't expect to get
all of those fish out.
We will find out when they
go into about a little larger
than a sac fry.
SPEAKER 1: Could you even
accommodate 10 millions striped
bass?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: No, and
that's why we hatched so many,
because we knew--
SPEAKER 1: It's like a wedding.
You hope not everybody comes.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Exactly!
Over-invite.
SPEAKER 1: Over-invite.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Our striped bass
are over-invited right now.
SPEAKER 1: So what is
the most complicated fish
you've attempted to farm in
terms of number of inputs,
or complexity of
the inputs required?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Right
now I will say, hands down,
my striped bass.
They have been extremely
challenging this year.
It is a fish that we're
just getting into.
We see them as a great fish.
Someone was asking why
do we grow what we grow.
Well, striped bass used to be a
great fish that a lot of people
would grow, but they grew
it for stocking purposes,
because they didn't travel
well to the live Asian markets.
Because once they went in,
they're such a fragile fish,
they would die.
Well, live market, dead
fish, that doesn't quite
work quite as well.
But for us, in a
processing environment,
it's a fantastic fish.
But we really, really
struggled with it.
This was our first
big year into it,
and it's a challenging
fish to spawn.
Really challenging.
SPEAKER 1: What's the
easiest one you've done?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: My
friend, the catfish.
The catfish love to propagate.
They just love to propagate.
You put a little music
on beside the lake.
SPEAKER 1: They do
the work for you.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: It
is, it's pretty simple.
We put out milk cans,
basically, that creates
little caves for them.
We're recreating that,
and you would not
believe that it's these
antique milk cans.
That is the secret to it.
We've tried to replicate
it in plastic and all
these other things, because
those milk cans are not
easy to come by, and people
want like a million bucks
for these silly things now.
SPEAKER 1: Super romantic
for a catfish, though.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yeah.
So you put those out there,
and you go out in there,
and usually Papa Catfish is
in their guarding the eggs.
But all in all, super
simple fish to deal with.
SPEAKER 1: I like it.
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
And that's actually
because we probably don't have
to mess with them too much.
SPEAKER 1: Interfere
that much, yeah.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Back to
the interference thing.
SPEAKER 1: Like we said,
and streamline the process.
Do you have--
AUDIENCE: Most
underrated fish that you
see becoming more popular
in the next couple years.
You'd mentioned catfish earlier.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Ooh.
Bill, what do you think on that?
BILL NGO: What was the question?
SPEAKER 1: What's
the dark horse?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yeah,
underrated fish that you think
is coming up.
SPEAKER 1: We want
to get in early.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Like they've
got a weak marketing team,
yeah.
They got a weak marketing team.
What's coming up?
SPEAKER 1: Salmon?
So over it.
What's next?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: What
do you think, Bill?
BILL NGO: I would say it's
the sturgeon right now.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: You think?
BILL NGO: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Sturgeon.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: I mean,
we are seeing it on a lot I
more menus.
BILL NGO: You guys see
it a lot at restaurants?
Not really, right?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yeah, we're
seeing it on a lot more menus,
and I think it's just interested
people like y'all that are
willing to go past that easily
marketed or that familiar fish.
I'm an adventurous eater.
I'll eat anything, anytime.
We had some fantastic
horse in Japan.
It was fantastic,
I really loved it.
SPEAKER 1: Did you say horse?
MICHAEL PASSMORE:
Horse, absolutely.
SPEAKER 1: Like, H-O-R-S-E?
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Yes,
like [NEIGHING] Mr. Ed.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
BILL NGO: So I
guess the sturgeon--
I'll go with him on that.
I wasn't going to go to one
of our fish, specifically.
But I think that caviar
production is rising.
And so through that, the level
of sturgeon is out there more,
and I think there's more
resources behind it,
so I think you're going
to hear more about it.
And they're taking
really good care of them
fish so that they get
a great roe from it.
So it stands to reason, I
think Bill's probably right
that that would be
an up-and-comer.
SPEAKER 1: Please join me, then.
Thank you guys so
much for coming.
MICHAEL PASSMORE: Thank
you for having me.
Thank you, Bill.
[APPLAUSE]